hey everyone what's up I milano charl
amazon and welcome to my channel today
we're talking about my highlights of EA
and nintendo's press conferences at e3
2015 I may also mention Square Enix but
I have a lot less to say about that one
so EA started off with some guy telling
us about how much we like video games
which is weird because I think everyone
at that conference already knows why
they like video games and then we got a
very very vague first look at mass
effect which is going to be called Mass
Effect Andromeda if fichu Marco or Meiko
the jumpy vehicle which I love from the
first one and then that looked a lot
more interactive and the music was
lovely graphics is great but we still
know next to nothing about the upcoming
Mass Effect and then we had a trailer
and you need to speed which as always
was incredibly pretty but seemed like
every other Need for Speed trailer I
have ever seen at this point it must be
extremely hard to make the speed
trailers different in the slightest the
way that you handle the car
customization did actually look really
cool though and a lot more extensive
than some of the most recent ether speed
games who have a car in your garage and
there's points on the car and you kind
of swap between them all and then adjust
sort of it almost made it look like
there's no menu I mean that in itself
obviously is just an interactive menu
but it was very sleek I lacked a design
the only issue with that is that it
looked like you have to circle the car
to get wherever you want you can't just
jump between those dots freely so I'm
assuming that that's an optional thing
and something that you can turn off
otherwise you have to scroll through
every single point of the car to get to
debris oh right tile or whatever and
then we saw some actual gameplay which
of course was pretty and shiny and had
lots of nice lens flare it also featured
during drifting the camera would sort of
tilt towards the car Apple this was a
really nice touch initially so it's
basically like the car as a car slides
into the corner the camera sort of
shifts to blow up shifts to lower and I
think that adds a lot to the atmosphere
of drifting which is something that
games don't really do a great job of
capturing so the only issue with this is
that I feel like it's going to make a
lot of people nauseous and
I think it's gonna make it really hard
to control the car so I'm wondering if
this is optional and then we saw unravel
which is a highlight for me for sure
unravel is a game that's inspired by
this little bowl of yon cat-like human
playing pool yani which we learn about
when the creator of the game was on
stage just holding this thing that he'd
actually made on a camping trip with his
family he was shaking like so much but
the passion and that was amazing he's
one of the most passionate people have
ever seen at a press conference the game
also looked really really sweet you play
as this thing made of yarn or string so
the idea is that you have to use the
string platform it kind of made me think
of re and I'm hoping that it has that
level of complexity but i'm not sure if
it will then those plants those zombies
I've never played it before but garden
warfare 2 does look really exciting the
animations in the trailer or gameplay
that we saw were fantastic musics also
really great sound design in general is
awesome and combat does look really
really fun so I may have to play the
first one while i wait for the second to
come out and it was sports time lata NHL
and MBAs and golf and madden and things
i don't care about they did show a nice
face scan thing for NBA which actually
looks like your books a lot of that face
scan technology in the past where it
puts your face onto a character in a
game is horrific and terrible but this
one actually looked really great it's
just a shame that I've limited to NBA
imagine if you could do that in a
bethesda game then we saw Mirror's Edge
catalyst which I'm so happy about so
it's actually going to be a prequel to
the first Mirror's Edge I will get to
play that one this week as well which
I'm very very very excited about faith
looks so so awesome graphics so great
apparently it's open world no loading
screens no levels I don't know how
that's gonna function when the first one
was actually really really linear I kind
of relied on on levels to get through
the story but I guess we'll see then
they showed us battlefront game play
finally graphics pastels but if I'm a
great the sound is perfect they they're
all original sound from the movies but I
feel like that's understating it just
sounds so authentic and it's incredible
it looks like there are a huge amount of
drivable vehicles and the hay
billing for all of them looks very
obviously different which I really like
as well so next up is Nintendo which I
have a fabulous to say about seemed like
that was a lot of co-op featured one of
the things was a 3ds coop Zelda kinda
seems like four swords which I'm totally
happy about then they showed some kind
of animal crossing mario party thing but
like not at all interactive it's kind of
happy to see new animal crossing but it
just it wasn't it's like the most
passive mario party ever then they
talked about Yoshi's woolly world which
is adorable and featured the oh she's
really well amoebas feel like it was
Nintendo's like time to show up EA and
be like yeah yeah well we made a whole
video game out of wool you just have
that one character then we saw a bunch
more about Super Mario maker which I'm
also going to be playing I think that
looks very very cool I'm excited about
the idea but during the Nintendo press
conference we also got to see like a lot
of really cool history stuff about
Nintendo it was a weird conference and
that we didn't learn that much and they
didn't really talk about games I mean
there's néomi bows there's a bit Mario
that's cool I mean really cool I had a
bunch of around Crossing amiibo and
stuff but for the most part was the most
entertaining one in like a kind of [ __ ]
Nintendo kind of way there was one point
where they showed Super Mario sketched
out on written paper like how they would
originally design levels and some of
those sheets of paper were older than I
am so that was very cool i would watch a
Nintendo documentary for sure I just
still really want them to announce
pokemon snap like please announce
pokemon snap all they needed to do was
show a little bit of Zelda that's all
they needed Zelda you that's it as for
square enix it was really weird they
showed a bunch of just cause gameplay
that was mostly to some mash up of three
second clips from things we've seen
before with overlay trying to sell it to
me it was not like a real trailer it was
it was bad I'm excited about just goes 3
and they made me bored then they
announced me a term which is being made
by platinum which is a big deal I never
thought you two would be made and I'm
sure it's so freaking ages away but I'm
glad it's being made then like a guy
came out with a weird masks and
yep and then I think Square Enix trolled
us they showed the same trailer for plan
a fantasy 7 and everyone wanted kingdom
hearts 3 and they like built it up for a
while and then showed us this mobile
game and then one of the guys on stage
was like hey Roy to some guy in the
crowd liked Roy's here like I'm pretty
sure that Square Enix just trolled us
but kingdom on Sri does actually look
really good the combat looks so much
better than the other game speed looks
fast and fluid and creative and that's
pretty much it unfortunately I'm
probably not going to have time to make
videos about the rest of the press
conferences but I hope you enjoyed this
video please let me know what you
thought to be 3 i'd love to hear you
guys opinions on these kinds of things
so that's it for today i wanna thank you
guys watching and I'll see you next time